you know some people have called joe
biden jimmy carter 2.0 but today we're
going to take a deep dive to see if
there's any patterns any trends any
commonalities and any differences
[Music]
all right so let's get right into it
look one thing you need to know is i'm
in america because of jimmy carter
because in 1977 december 31st president
carter went to iran and he had a toast
with the shah and everything was great
it was iran's a friend of u.s they were
a friend of ours and then they leave
then khomeini comes in to revolt his
people nine million people revolution in
iran shah's folks are calling carter for
help kissinger for help at first they
say we got your back don't worry about
it last minute kissingen carter says we
can't help you nobody comes to help iran
iran falls shaw's in exile romani comes
in in february nine years later we
escape iran and go to germany at a
refugee camp and eventually come out
here so president carter because of him
i'm in the united states having said
that there's a little bit of history
here with me and the carter
administration well let's get right into
it so we got carter we got biden 39 46
okay
former peanut farmer carter former
governor of georgia biden 51 years
politician that's what he's done okay
electoral votes when he won he got 297
votes he got 306. total votes uh carter
got 40.8 million we all know biden's the
most popular president ever he got 81
plus million votes according to data
uh carter ran once for president
biden ran for president three times once
in 88 once in 2008 and once in 2020 and
that's when he won so now we know their
background now here's what makes these
two
very very interesting both of them
are are folks who were never seen as
number ones meaning
in 88 and 2008 when biden ran nobody
ever said you know he's going to be a
president they were never seen as number
ones they were both good number twos
number fours number five number six is
never number one however
carter comes right after watergate nixon
big personality watergate happens boom
beautiful opportunity you know next
thing you know ford doesn't get
reelected carter gets in
biden comes in post trump cobit crisis
happens oh my gosh we don't want
somebody like that we got to go complete
opposite so it's like it's like a girl
dating a guy who's a big personality you
know like mackenzie she's married to
jeff bezos we're going to take over the
world she says i'm so sick and tired of
dating a guy that wants to take over the
world i just want a school teacher right
we went from trump to biden that's what
we did that's america same as here right
now let's continue inflation when carter
was president at first inflation was 5.8
percent by the time he was done it was
13 and a half percent now watch this
here we only have data for nine months
when biden was first president
january 2021 inflation was only 1.4
percent
just nine months later it's 5.4 percent
not a year later not two years later not
four years later in only nine months
it's 5x nearly inflation so that's just
inflation right let's continue
major foreign crisis and hostage
situation during carter it was iran 52
american citizens were held hostage the
day
reagan is doing its inauguration iran
releases the 52 hostage they're free
us during biden afghanistan which was an
absolute
mess that took place with the sequencing
on how we left everybody wanted to leave
but the way we left where we left the
city we left the citizens first and you
know the way we just made no sense how
u.s left and then we left all that
equipment for taliban
major screw-up here
major screw-up here 52 held hostage some
say there's 8 000 held in hostage i put
the number a thousand right this is a
massive massive screw-up we still don't
know the side effects of afghanistan we
know the side effects of what happened
in iran when iran went through their
mess we don't yet know the side effects
of what's going to happen here with
taliban and afghanistan but they're
major major screw-ups in foreign policy
next gas prices
carter when he first gets elected at 61
cents a gallon during that time that's
the absolute gas price of that time by
the time he leaves his buck 25 which
means it's double now here's biden
2020 gas prices are 2016. today october
today gas prices are 337. a city in
california today gas prices are at 758 a
city and central coast of california
today it's 758 per gallon and this is
not even close to what inflation is
doing right now so we don't know what's
going to happen with gas prices but we
see the trends on where it's going
approval rating
carter he was at 45.5 percent lowest was
28.3
approval rating for biden as of right
now is at 38
he's the lowest i believe of the last
five presidents minus trump trump was
slightly lower than he was i think
around 35 or 34 some number like that
let's continue
misery index which is
unemployment and inflation combined
together okay so misery index for carter
sixteen point two six percent highest
was twenty percent for biden when he got
elected it was only seven point seven
percent but nine months later it's 11.3
so it's gone up nearly 50 in just in
nine months of misery index again
unemployment and you got inflation right
so keep this part of mind as well the
last few months every month they said
we're expecting 540 000 new jobs 180.
we're expecting 720 000 new jobs 200. so
it's a pretty scary thought on what's
going on with jobs as well next
a border mishap when carter was
president on cuba
he was trying to do human rights because
that was a big part of his campaign say
well it's not fair castro what you're
doing and castro outsmarted him and he
says you want our people no problem
we're going to let people free but
here's how it's going to work he opened
up his prison he let go of
125 000 prisoners he released into miami
miami's unemployment goes to 50
during that time it was a mess and we
know when you think about cocaine or
certain things you think about one city
which is what miami major mishap with
borders cuba now in u.s today mishap
under biden mexico every single day
you're talking about what's going on
with mexico you know he he's not letting
you know political refugees that are
coming here from cuba but he's okay with
folks that are not coming in here from
you know mexican border whether it's you
know some places are even open borders
they're saying where people are just
walking across now both are
conversations that are coming up on a
daily basis
fed chair
card against volcker he says we got to
get a hold this inflation thing biden
has powell today
and not much has changed i think powell
may be increasing interest rates here
very soon look
people say
you know biden's the jimmy carter 2.0
i'm like listen that sounds good but i
want to go do research and then you see
this and you're like i kind of see a lot
of similarities with what's going on
maybe neither one of them were you know
good number ones maybe they're both good
men i don't know by now i've never had
dinner with them i've never seen him
around as kids i don't know how he's as
a grandfather i don't know how he's as a
father i don't know how he's as a friend
neither do i know about jimmy carter but
i've heard good things i've heard good
things about carter at least carter
lowered capital gains i think from 49 to
like 25 because he was trying to save
the economy at least carter tried to
deregulate many of these different
industries he was trying to say look we
got to do something with business owners
because he was a former farmer but biden
wants to increase taxes so
if i'm trying to give a break here but
everything's going to even worse
than what happened here so we just got a
brace for impact because the reality of
it right now is we have full data here
we know what happens here we don't have
full data here we only have nine months
we have another three years to go to see
what's going to happen and the verdict
you know verdicts out because he may
turn it around we don't know that yet
but here's what we do know
you know what happened after carter
ready
12 years
of republican president
eight years reagan four years
bush senior we have no idea what's going
to happen here but i can tell you the
way things are going right now this is a
time for you to be prepared in case the
market crashes this is a time for you to
be prepared in case inflation goes up
this is a time for you to actually study
the market to find out how this can
directly affect you
and the people you love the most this is
not a time to kind of say oh
i don't need to know this kind of stuff
it's probably the most important time to
know what's going to happen to the
economy because
one of these things flips in a major way
it affects everything else and god knows
we have a lot of fake success going on
in america right now so that my
recommendation to you would be
definitely study more about what's going
on today because some things are about
to happen on this side having said that
if you like the video you got value from
the video give it a thumbs up subscribe
to the channel i got two other videos i
want you to watch
one of them is the details of inflation
how it works if you've never watched
videos on how inflation works click over
here and the other one is
eight ways to prepare for an economic
collapse i did that video i think a year
and a half two years ago if you've never
seen that click on this clip to watch
that video take care everybody bye
[Music]